okay let me tell you about something
very very odd that's going on and it's
actually horrible like really really
horribly destructive for the finances of
the show our show has many sources of
revenue one of those sources is patreon
we've been using it for a year and a
half or so we've got around 1,700 or so
donors who contribute monthly on patreon
another funding source for the show is
membership and that this story makes me
so upset it's hard to even put into
words with membership we used to accept
payment via something called Amazon pay
which means you signed up for membership
on our website but a payment option was
Amazon pay and then the Preta
the payments were processed by Amazon
it's sort of like Amazon's equivalent of
PayPal or stripe a few years ago Amazon
phased out this payment method so we
stopped allowing it for new members but
existing members using this thing called
Amazon pay we're still allowed to use it
and what we said was when your
membership expires transition over to a
different form of payment but a lot of
our members still are on Amazon pay this
is so confusing and maybe you can help
me figure it out I got an email from
Amazon pay yesterday saying that because
of our patreon account Amazon pay is
suspending our Amazon pay account and
keeping all of our money okay let's see
if we can figure out what they meant the
email they sent me says we have closed
your amazon pay account cancelled
pending transactions and placed a
temporary hold on any funds in your
account we took these actions because
your website patreon.com slash david
pakman show may be in violation of our
acceptable use policy which prohibits
the use of our payment service for
transactions involving charitable
solicitations by any entity without a
valid 501c3 tax-exempt status what they
sort of seem to be saying is that
they see us on patreon soliciting funds
which they interpret to be charitable
solicitations but we're not a 501c3 and
therefore they believe the funds that we
are receiving via Amazon pay are also
charitable funds solicited without being
a non-profit 501c3 so therefore they are
banning us from Amazon pay and
impounding all of our money I
immediately appealed this saying what on
earth does patreon have to do with
Amazon we don't claim to be a non-profit
we are a for-profit people sign up for
membership what the hell is going on and
I got an email back from Amazon pay
within a few hours which of course
they've taken very seriously saying
simply after reviewing your account we
have decided not to reinstate your
Amazon pay account any remaining funds
are being reserved in your account they
may be held for 90 days after 90 days or
the completion of investigations funds -
claims and charge backs will be made
available for withdrawal in speaking to
Amazon about that they said there is no
guarantee at all that the funds will be
made available if indeed we are found to
be in continuing violation of the policy
which of course we will be because we
have membership and patreon and we
depend on funding from the audience so
what can I do probably nothing we are
losing that money we are losing those
members and this is really not a good
use of my time time that could be spent
making shows researching stories
preparing for interviews as you can
probably imagine so Amazon is attacking
us because we are on patreon I've got
people emailing me mad about patreon
because some of the recent controversies
related to them so here's my ask and we
can get past this so easily if you
currently support the show on membership
or patreon you don't have to do anything
don't worry about it you don't need to
change a thing if you were using Amazon
pay to support us
or if you want to help us fight back
against this and the thousands of
dollars in lost revenue that it
represents just grab a membership on our
website wwlp.com we control the entire
process you can use any credit or debit
card if you have a paypal account you
can use a linked bank account or any
payment method you have linked to PayPal
you can now transfer cryptocurrency into
PayPal and then use PayPal to get a
membership we pay two point nine percent
plus $0.30 no big fees no risk of any of
this stuff people emailing me lately
saying we want you to get off patreon
how can I support you without going
through some other service that maybe
will suppress speech we've had the
solution for a long time membership on
our website please help us push back
against this because this is really just
at the end of the year someone coming
and saying here's thousands of dollars
you're losing and thousands of dollars
that we may also hold for 90 days or
indefinitely if we don't like what it is
that you're doing memberships start at
six bucks a month if you want a 40%
discount use the coupon code this is
20/20 that will make a monthly
membership three dollars and sixty cents
a month we can fight back against this
we have total control over the payment
process and the entire thing when you
sign up at wwlp.com don't let them do
this to us it's yet another one of these
attempts to sideline the work that we're
doing